[Music]
hey what's up I'm Jesse welcome back to
the wool from tech conference 2018 if
you weren't here before I've been just
been talking to developers and other
interesting people who are using
technology America ways and I'm sitting
here with Ricardo could you tell us a
little bit about yourself what you do it
Wolfram and what you're focused on I'm
from Italy yeah
and I work from home I work remotely
which is a great thing about this
company allows you to work remotely I
actually started working of the world
from summer school which is basically a
school that we are doing in the summer
when we where people can come and learn
about foreign language and yes instead
have been working for like five years
now so what do you do like what team are
you on
I am on a small team since I I started
working pretty early in data validation
with interpreter for function my
background is from I'm a web developer
and so I've been focused on web
technology and right now and be working
on database integration and what we will
show here I think is something that
branch out from the database integration
project because we were using Python
internally and and
and we figured out that there was a
corner of what we were doing that was
interesting for other people so we
decided to to branch it out and make it
like an independent project so what
exactly is Oh what are the current ways
that Wolfram language can interact with
Python right now well since version I
think he was 11.2 I guess we started
externally valid that is like a generic
framework to interact with other
languages we currently support it in
Java Python and JavaScript probably also
the Chrome extension and and and and
this was done via a Python link that
that is sending messages through
basically the the notebook to the Python
and sending back messages again as the
Python response and and and since then
we started we started improving the way
this message was working and we created
a library that allows you to interact
with with Python either like to this
library in particular is the other way
around is to start the kernel from
Python or to create Wolfram language
code directly from Python or to read
word from language code directly from
Python which is something new that we
are planning to release very soon on and
eat up as an open source project so an
effect the Wolfram language is an
external library for Python like any
other sort of libraries
why do you say so the Wolfram language
itself is basically like a library in
this case so how does this sort of
library what are some common
applications you see with this like what
is a common work library but this
library is uh you know your for example
there are a lot of amazing library for
Python I think a lot of pattern
developers know that there is a whole
ecosystem of enthusiastic developers
that are developing a lot of very nice
library that goes from web development
to machine learning to everything like
that and sometimes you are producing a
lot of data within those library one
example is numpy that we are that there
is using data science which is a very
fast library that allows you to do
operation directly on syriza and and and
we support basically serialization of
all those arrays directly into word from
language 12.2 row array they're cool now
they were cool numeric array I think no
doubt Urkel numerically yes and
basically you can sterilize all your
data as numeric array in double excel
format which is a format that we
implemented in
and so and then you can import back all
this data from Mathematica and continue
from there this is an example workflow
or you can extract data from or from
language expertise wxf reported back in
Python do some analyses export them back
and continue for some languages there
are all kinds of possibilities even with
the library you can start the kernel
within Python you will start a pool of
kernel from Python and I'm paralyzed
basically your computation or four or
five car nuts in a pool and do them in
parallel yeah so those are a couple of
example of things you can do
the library is gonna be available very
soon link yeah can you show me a little
bit this is this is a preview I mean
this is the documentation I was planning
to to show for example you see that it's
gonna be on people so it's gonna be very
silly storages do peep installer from
client and and you can do basically
there are tools to do evaluation
directly with the same API either on
your local machine you see that you just
need to insert the part of your local
Python installation so I don't know like
on OSX it's gonna be slash up leash on
Mathematica or whatever you start the
session and then you can use this syntax
which is very nice in Python that allows
you to create Wolfram language code
directly using this Factory there is a
dynamic object in Python and then you
can just value it in the gardener and
get back to result
as a Python object and the end rod API
is basic the API is the same whatever
you are interacting with your local
kernel or with a cloud camera so you can
either spoon I don't know like tanker
that's directly on the cloud or you can
spawn can answer your machines the FBI
is gonna do the same so you can start by
developing things locally and then move
to the cloud when when you are on
production or the other way around so
this library allows you to obstruct the
interaction with the kernel very easily
and to only focus basically on the
computation and things that you need to
do it is actually is a very nice
interface because compared to other
languages the panel allows you to have a
very nice syntax something that you
cannot really have in to do this dynamic
nature you cannot really do the same in
Java or in JavaScript it's something
that is just I think impossible but with
the center's basically you can you can
create expressions and you see here you
can mix like expressions that are either
like verbatim so from a string or by
using those cool structure that that
Python allows you to do so this is
actually now a Python object that you
construct and you can construct any kind
of arbitrary expression with the
symptoms it's very nice I've been using
it a lot and it really works great the
other thing that you can do here is that
you can have
the system is used in in in notebooks
and you can just start by themselves
hopefully it's and pattern cells are
something new in in in the notebooks and
allows you to yeah I think it should be
shift and so these this is just a
computation is running by using external
evaluate and and it's using the very
same library so internally we're using
this library to convert world from
expression to bite on and read them back
and we are always searching the the
library that we are internally using
early so that people can also can also
use it and can manually from within
pattern create expressions and and then
communicate back with the governor and
so on yeah so we have been using these
de synthesis three it's really really
nice and the other thing that you knew
here is to use the rule error
serialization
there are functions to serialize and
deserialize and there is a single ABI
the three videos and and basically the
same the same functions allow you to
serialize put in the input fun which is
human readable but then by just changing
the format you can you can now produce
wxf which is a binary representation of
the world from language and it's way
faster and more compact and it's more
like to communicate from machine to
machine and you just need to change you
see one line of code and and then you
are civilizing using another format can
you talk a little bit more about for now
exactly so for now the cloud can be used
to basically spawn kernels and so let's
say that you need to do like a very long
computation or something that needs to
be parallelized
then what you can do is that from your
from your machine you you describe the
the corroboration and the data
collection then you basically use them
some kind of MapReduce method where
basically you are just mapping those
those expression to several kernels and
and on the cloud you can spawn how many
animals you want and and basically
paralyze your your computation I don't
know like used to Antechinus in parallel
dirty and reduce the time of the
computation and and and and get back the
an aggregated result and then you can
continue working on Python or yeah
so for now yes the white on didi is not
really allowed for security reason right
now to rather be very good on the cloud
platform so you cannot really run
directly a parameter on the cloud but
from Python on your local machine even
like on a virtual machine or WS or
digitalocean or whatever you can
communicate to the world from cloud if
you are having a private cloud or
something you can install of course
Python and then and then use it there
but for the moment the cloud you need to
interact with externally and yeah and
you can basically start yeah caramel
cool and to what otherwise your
operations cool this is really cool it
seems like a huge sort of step in there
would be where do you see this library
or any sort of external connections to
Python like where do you see this going
the next couple of years
I hope people will get excited by that
and we actually we actually want to get
back to being us from the community
obviously we want to know you know how
people are using this thing if it's
getting useful we want to have like
feedback from Ebola feeders requests for
now we are we we are maintaining this
library and we and we we really want to
optimize the performance I mean like
from I don't have the numbers right now
but I think like we did a huge
performance improvement by using this
code from eleven point two to twelve
which is at least 100 percent faster but
again I don't have the exact numbers and
and the library can be optimized even
further because we can add C extensions
and so like this réaliser and the DC
réaliser can be even faster for now did
the performance is is great because
numpy Eraser are are directly taking the
zero presentation and they are pushing
to the wxf serialization but for but
again i I hope that we can have
suggestion and maybe even pull request
from other people you know right now we
are supporting all in on Pi but I guess
there are a lot of other framers like
again think about bandha and other
things that we want to support so so
this is gonna be on github for anyone
just get there should be too awesome
do you have anything else you want you
want to talk about related to no not
really I mean the the library there is a
whole documentation here
we are the nice thing here is that we
are natively supporting a lot of all
built-in data types from Python
starting from integer floating point
decimal precision and an everything that
is related to built-in dates so data
object time object time Delta are
translated into entities and fractions
as well are also translated into
rational so we have like support for all
built-in types and for some external
library we think we are useful like
numpy yeah no I really really excited
about this project because I'm a parent
developer a parent two years so I think
he's gonna yeah cool thanks for your
talking with me
yeah and thanks for hanging out with us
today okay